- My mother and Arthur
Schlesinger were great friends
and they used to have a
playful teasing with each other
and it was 50/50 who would
get the better of who.
But Arthur was known for
on somebody's birthday or special occasion
like today he would say,
"Well, today is the day
"that the first can of beer
was canned in America and
"the first game was played in
the American Baseball League
"and also Governor Winthrop's telescope
"was burned in the Harvard fire."
Those things actually
all did happen today.
- [Host] Right.
- And so my mother said, "Well look
"Arthur may be smart
but he's not that smart.
"He's got a book that he's
looking this stuff up in.
"So when we go out to play tennis
"why don't you into Arthur's
room and find the book
(host and audience laughing)
"and I will embarrass him at dinner."
And I said, "Mom, you want me
to go into your guest's room?"
And she was like, "Yeah"
(host and audience laughing)
So I did.
And so when Mom got back
from tennis she said,
"Did you find the book?"
And I said, "Yeah."
She said, "Well do you have it?"
I said, "I'm not going to take the book
"out of Arthur's room, Mom."
She said, "Well, what's the book called?"
I said, "It's called the
Almanac of American History
"by Arthur Schlesinger."
(laughter)